everybody and welcome to the second part
of our PI game with Python 3 game
development tutorial video in the last
video what we covered was just creating
a very basic window understanding the
bare minimum of a PI game how it's
initialized how it's ended as well as
events and stuff like that so the first
thing I'd like us to do is just get rid
of this print event statement we don't
need that anymore that was just going to
clog up on our console and now we want
to add or a few other things generally
at the top of everyone's script you're
going to see a lot of the very same
stuff okay so um first of all we're
going to want to change how we're
displaying the games size so I want to
do this for a lot of reasons one of the
reasons is if we want to resize the game
or offer an option later on to say hey
we want a different resolution of the
game then we can do that also the more
major reason is a lot of times you're
going to reference the games size either
width or height to create events or to
display things so to display text for
example you want to say where you want
that text to be well if the window is
800 Y by 600 tall great we're probably I
display some text either at the top left
which would be 0 0 but what if we want
to display text in the middle well we
need to know those dimensions so we need
to be able to reference those dimensions
so this is just kind of bad practice to
do it this way so the first thing we're
going to go ahead and do is we're going
to make some variables instead so will
they say display underscore width equals
800 and then we're going to say display
oops
display underscore height equals 600 and
then we'll take this copy paste and then
copy paste so now just a set mode
display with display height so now not
only can we edit these later on we can
reference them later on and we can
modify them later on and everybody's
happy so that's the first thing we want
to do now another thing that you're
going to see you're probably more often
than you're gonna see than this
of people really we'll just hard code it
right into there but just not really the
best idea what you're going to see in
most people's code is color definitions
right at the top I kind of wish pygame
had some color definitions by default
like black like red white or red white
red orange yellow green blue
you know purple black and white would
make a lot of sense but they don't yeah
I guess I was okay but generally you're
going to see everybody is defining at
least black and white right out of the
gate and the way that you're going to
define colors is with the RGB method I
guess and so it's going to be black
equals a certain tuple and then white
equals a certain tuple now just in case
you guys aren't familiar first of all
colors in computing are measured with
RGB and the idea here and the why
because RGB stands for red green blue so
when you define a color like black it's
going to be zero zero zero because it's
gonna be there's literally like no black
or no color in black which is quite
opposite of what you know of black you
know today like black is like the
absence a like if you were to mesh every
color like with paint or something and
you were painting and you meshed all the
colors you'd wind up with something
pretty black whereas here the black is
like the absence of all color whereas
and then white is the is all colors here
which I suppose is sort of the way of
white is today even like white is
supposed to contain our colors anyway
let's knock it on that tangent and let's
just define why we use RGB instead of
our like red yellow blue so the primary
colors that you're probably taught in
school red yellow blue because you know
red plus yellow makes orange and yellow
and blue makes green and so on and
obviously red is red well the way that
works is if you take a paintbrush and
paint some some red and then you paint
some yellow the yellow kind of brightens
the right a little bit and add
that kind of tinge of yellow so it makes
it orange but that's with like it's
basically as you add more you're taking
away light whereas when you take with
computers we use RGB because the idea is
with computers we have at least in the
old days what you had like a backlight
and it would use light to display colors
so if you had two flashlights and you
put like saran wrap over them one was
like green saran wrap and the other one
was blue saran wrap or something you you
turn them both on you turn the blue on
it would be very blue and you turn the
green on it would be very green and if
you cross them over you would see at the
crossover point it didn't get darker
like it would if you painted paints it
got lighter right because you added more
light to it so that's why we use a
little bit of a different system in
computers nowadays it's all like
generated digitally pretty much but
that's why we use RGB with computers so
that means what's white going to be but
white is going to be the maximum of all
colors each of these colors that we can
put in here is anything you have 256
choices for each color so the
combinations are 256 by 256 by 256 right
so so anyway
white is going to be 255 255 255 and why
is that
because one of your options is of course
zero so why it's 255 255 255 but you
could also have red for example red
would be we already said this is RGB
right so r is for red so red would be
255 0 0 easy enough green would be 0 255
0 and so on one of the things I like to
do is and we'll show later on as I just
go to like a website and you can like
pick a color out of like a nice like
color wheel basically and it'll give you
the RGB I find that's the easiest way to
make fancy colors but you can certainly
make black white red green blue really
easily you don't really have to memorize
anything besides RGB anyway moving on
we'll be fine with black-and-white for
now we will eventually move away from
black-and-white but for now black/white
is fine so that's RGB
now we we need some sort of like game
character and we could you PI game has a
thing built-in where you can draw shapes
and stuff and you can draw things we
will use that but at least for a little
mangled character which will be for us a
car or at least for me a car you can do
whatever you want you can make a boat
for all I care
we're going to actually draw that so I'm
going to show you guys how we can
actually draw something and then we can
use that in PI game so I'll show you
guys both how to load up an image into
by PI game and use that image
dynamically in the walls to also show
you guys how you can draw things in PI
game and manipulate what you've drawn as
well so show both of those things so now
what I want to do either you could go
online and just get a picture of like a
race car or something that you find
interesting or you can draw one I think
it's more fun to draw one personally so
I drew mine in paint I'll just show a
real sped up version of me drawing in
and paint and then also I want to cover
for my windows users how we can make a
transparent background because you for
us our background will be white but if
our car crosses over anything that white
edges of the car is going to cross over
you might also want to change
backgrounds or whatever it's always good
if you're making games that whatever
images you load you make a transparent
background not a white background it's
cheesy so that's so we're going to do
that as well so anyway um I'll show me
drawing my little car if you want some
inspiration otherwise you can draw your
own car also just upload my car image
for anybody who wants to use my car
image but it's more fun to draw your own
so I encourage you to draw your own um
but I will upload mine and then finally
I just sense it I think it is a big
important thing if you're making games
and you want to load images you should
know how to make transparent backgrounds
if you're on like Mac or something like
that it's actually really easy to do but
if you're on Windows it's not so much so
for windows I recommend a program called
[ __ ] you've probably heard of it I don't
like it very much but to make a
transparent background on [ __ ] it's
super easy so um anyway I'll show me
drawing the car and then I'll come back
and show you guys how you can edit an
image real quick for no background on
[ __ ] so let's do that
okay once you have your image I want to
show you guys how to make a transparent
background with [ __ ] [ __ ] you have to
download and install [ __ ] but once you
do I'm trying to find [ __ ] anyways see
if I can okay finally found [ __ ] there
hopefully this will open up [ __ ] for us
maybe not there it is okay take that
[ __ ] up man just unlike [ __ ] so when you
get [ __ ] up you get like all these
little windows part of why I hate [ __ ]
but what we can do is we can go file
open and we can open up one of our
images trying to find let's see an image
that okay I think yeah so we'll use my
old race car image so here's the image
whatever you have so this is our awesome
race car but as you can see that the
background is white and with [ __ ] it's
super easy you just go pro I think it's
colors and then color to alpha hit that
by default they just say hey from white
basically you can click this and you can
pick any color but for us we want to
convert white to alpha and so that's all
we've done it we're gonna do its by
default there you hit okay boom you have
converted the image to alpha now you'll
go file export as and you can save you
know the new images whatever you want so
that's just a quick example of how you
can add a transparent background like I
said don't really mean to do any image
editing you can tell I'm not much of an
image editor Oh graphics guy but it's
definitely fun to have transparent
backgrounds and I found out how easy it
was to do it in Windows with [ __ ] so
boom transparent background now once you
have your car image what you're going to
want to do is somewhere around here
we'll make some space scroll up a little
bit and now we're just going to say car
IMG and that's going to equal pi game
image low
and then what what do we want to load
and this is for me it's race card dot
PNG make sure that the image is in the
same directory as your script otherwise
it's not going to work
but you could put the full path you know
C colon slash Bubble Bobble but if it's
in the same directory this should be
fine um let's run like Linux or
something sometimes that throws to you
gets angry but anyway that is our image
so to load up an image we just do that
but obviously that image is not shown
yet so just so you know that's just
loaded into the background basically so
we load that and now we actually want to
display that so to display our car we're
just going to make a real simple
function that displays the car in it in
to display it we have to say where we
want to display it so again it's it's
necessary to be able to reference width
and height here's the first reason so we
can say we're on here we can make
somewhat dynamic for us we don't really
necessarily have to make it too dynamic
but we can so um crash equals false
we're going to leave that near our while
loop there but now we're going to define
some of our functions and our first
function is going to define car and car
is going to have only two parameters
will be x and y : and now for for car
we're going to say game display so we're
referencing this variable up here which
is just the PI game display dot set mode
game display dot lit and what blitt is
going to do is it's basically like
drawing to your little background stuff
whatever we're asking for since it's an
image we've lit it to a surface and so
we go blitt then we've lit car image so
we're bleeding what the car image and
then where are we going to be lit it and
again we need a tuple here because this
is a single parameter so we where we
bled it X X Y so whatever X&Y we put in
here that's where we're going to blitt
the car image which just so happens to
be this variable which happens to be our
car picture so that's what our car
function is going to do for displaying
the car
now again I just want to reiterate XY
has to be a tuple in its own little
brackets and here's a reason car image
is a parameter so if we just did this it
would think x and y we're separate
parameters when really it's all one
parameter so we definitely want to have
those brackets there don't forget now to
start our cars location we could just
hard code it we could say well we want
it to be at the bottom in the middle we
could do that and now it also be a good
idea to explain location of things with
computers again not the same as what you
were taught in school so in school you
know when you have like a graph let's
say you've got your graph like this and
got your axes I don't really know where
y'all are yeah someone's opposite but
you have an axes and then as you go up
the axes x increases and Y increases
right and if you go into the negatives X
is basically going down and and all that
or well X doesn't depend which way
you're moving but Y is going down for
example so things are measured in
general as your time the bottom left is
0 0 well in computers that's the
opposite so up here is where x and y
begin is like right here so 0 0 for
computers is actually up in the upper up
left as you add it to X you move over to
the right so that's you know the same
but as you add to Y you actually move
down so just keep that in mind so
that'll trip you up sometimes so keep
that in mind
um and with that where do we want this
car to start now we want the car to
start x equals and we're going to say we
want the car to start at whatever a
display width is x we kind of want it in
the middle but if we put it smack in the
middle again it's going to reference the
car on the by the top left or basically
so the top left so if you say that's out
of the half then really if the image was
big enough it would be like way over the
a little bit more I want to be centered
so for now we'll just say 0.45 and then
y equals a display high whoops
height times 0.8 again if you say y
equals display height we reference the
image by the upper left so that's where
Y is is the top so if you set y equals
display height the image would be off
the screen it would be like one pixel
off the screen so we really want that or
early I suppose it might be one pixel on
the screen but you wouldn't notice it so
we do that so X Y now we have crashed
equals false great while not crashed we
run the loop and then whenever this loop
basically this loop here is like our
logic loop of events so we have an event
handling loop and then as I misspoke so
this is our just our event handling loop
right so for event in that so we put all
the inputs and events and stuff like
that that we do to the game in this loop
and we don't yet have a logic loop but
you'll see in a little bit how it one's
not necessarily the logic loop but it's
a group of logic and for us it'll be a
bunch of if statements basically but
anyway we don't have any logic to our
game yet we just have event handling but
we'll get there so anyway to show our
car we would do for example car X Y and
that's it because X Y is defined up here
as the starting point and then if we
wanted to move our car we could modify X
Y somewhere in this while loop and we
would move the car and then the only
other thing that's necessary is right
now our background is whether there is
no background we we kind of want to
change the background color so we're
going to change the background we're
going to say surfeit or game display dot
fill and then in here we can specify
what we want to fill the game display
with and we want to fill it with white
so anything that was there before just
got like written over basically with the
color of white and then we draw the car
if you did it in the reverse it's really
important that you put this first before
we draw the car because if you did it
this way if you did car and then game
display dot fill white what would happen
is it would draw the car and then it
would just
just basically paint a bunch of white
over the car and you wouldn't see the
car right so that's not that's not what
we want so for example we could run it
and we just get this white window a bit
racy there's nothing on it like but the
cars there it's just been painted over
basically so you take the car and you
put it under like that and so the car
drawing happens second and now we have a
car on her screen so again it's just
really important that you take these the
order of things that you draw into
consideration because it literally will
draw them in that order
and then it shows it so keep that in
mind so close out of this yes and then
after you're done doing all of the
drawing that you want to do update and
that will show it to the screen you can
also do dot flip so I'll just show that
just just for these four coupes should
be the same thing right so it's just the
same thing I like update you can do flip
you can do whatever you want flips just
kind of a good idea to think of because
like flip is kind of closely related to
what's hat it's kind of reminds me of
like a flipbook you know that's kind of
what games are anyways because all the
game is update is you know it gives you
the notion of movement but nothing
actually moves it's just redrawing of
frames moving things just slightly in
the background you just change the
position of things slightly and each
little thing like a flipbook would and a
flipbook gives you the impression that
something is moving but nothing's
actually moving it's just frames being
refreshed so anyway so flip kind of is a
is a good one just to think of because
that's how you kind of visualize
movement in games is like a flipbook
anyway um this seems like a good place
to stop we've got um our image we drew
our little main character whatever it is
a race car did the transparent
background we showed how we can load
that image up and now we're ready to
start doing a few more interesting
things
so anyways stay tuned to the next video
if you guys have any questions or
comments on this video feel free to
leave them below I'll be happy to help
as always thanks for watching thanks for
all the support the subscriptions and
until next time